[Music]
chances are your wallet's just a little
lighter these days with prices
continuing to skyrocket compared to this
time last year americans are paying on
average nearly a dollar forty more for a
gallon of regular gas that's one way you
can tell the cost of a gallon of two
percent milk that's up 42 cents from a
year ago according to moody's analytics
rising prices are costing u.s households
now listen to this number almost 300
more a month with little signs of
slowing down yikes this morning we're
learning about some very simple apps
that can help ease the financial pain so
to speak cnet money editor at large
that's farnoosh tarabi joins us now to
hopefully give you some help this
morning because when you hear the number
three hundred dollars a month that's a
big chunk for many many people a month
it can be life-changing i mean three
hundred dollars is um extra child care
it is being able to pay down your
student loans more effectively so this
is substantive and i think it's going to
get a little bit more painful before we
are out of the woods so let's start with
gas prices i was in la last week i
actually saw a sign a price for 7.99 oh
my gosh 7.99 i know it's not that high
in most places but it is higher you need
the gas buddy app okay so gas buddy
essentially gas body's been around for
years essentially helping you find the
lowest fuel prices wherever you are it
uses your eight your phones a gps you
first go into the app it asks what kind
of fuel you want premium regular and
then it will using your gps tell you
what are the lowest priced gas in your
area you can also do a map view and see
we're using new york city as an example
in our demo but you know if you're on
the upper west side you want to go to
tribeca you might see what's in tribeca
and think and plan ahead i'm going to
get gas while i get to my destination
very interesting the other thing is food
food prices are going up every single
week in the supermarket teddy can reach
for a new item and that item is more
expensive than the week before people
crying in the produce aisles i mean it
is a tough place in the supermarket
you've got an app that might be able to
help flip flip is an app it is free to
use essentially takes out the work of
bringing your coupons and your reward
cards to the grocery store it stores it
for you securely in the app you start by
making your list you know bread chicken
whatever and then you can click on the
individual items to see what are the
deals at the grocery stores that you've
already told the app that you like and
it will tell you where to go get those
deals you can also swipe to find
circulars at all of your favorite
grocery store so you know where to save
before you leave the house yeah there's
an app you know where people say there's
an app for that but you have some app
that
anything from clothes to pet food so
retail is not it's called retailmenot
i've been using this for years
you have to pay for these some of them a
lot of what we're going to talk about
they are free i will mention if they are
not um but retailmenot is an app and
it's now also an extension to your
browser so you can use it while you're
on the go in the store with your app as
well as when you're shopping online it
will tell you if there are coupon codes
cash back offers discounts for wherever
you're shopping and there are 20 000
retailers as you mentioned everyone from
a target to a door dash everyone in
between uh i'm the big cook in my
household cooked dinner almost every
night except for friday nights and when
you go out it's a little bit more
expensive these days anything that can
help on that front i like to use raise
it's an app where you can buy and sell
gift cards so raise your hand if you've
ever gotten a gift card that you didn't
really want to use
so raise is a marketplace you can sell
that and oftentimes the value of the
gift card is higher than what you will
pay for it so we did a browse we found
an applebee's gift card valued at 50 but
you only pay 42 and change so with a
savings of 14 i call this saving money
before you even get to the restaurant
that's interesting though doesn't it say
not transferable on the back of those
gift cards maybe i don't know
goodbye
i was going to say most of them do say
yeah most of them do say non-training
listen i won't tell i won't tell on you
okay okay there's another you know when
you're growing up you always hear every
penny counts yes that's a real thing
that was a real thing in my house you
say there's even an app for that yes
true bill that puts that into yeah
because we often forget how much we're
spending you know these memberships and
subscriptions we're signing up for left
and right streaming services i signed up
for just automatically you do yeah and i
mean as far as how much we think we're
spending versus the reality it's a big
difference um true bill is an app that
will help you identify firstly identify
awareness is key what are the expenses
that are recurring in your budget and
then it can go and actually advocate for
you negotiate these bills there's a fee
for this if you want them to actually go
and call up these merchants for you but
even just the awareness alone i realized
i signed up for this blow dry you know
two a month pay sixty dollars i was like
yeah i'm totally very ambitious of me
did not use this gail and then i called
and they said no problem we'll cancel it
and you've got eight blow dries you can
use until the end of may because you
have a deficit there's an app for blow
dryer no it's not an app it's a local
place but you know what i i just
realized that you're not using it so i
called and it was 60 bucks a month so
when when things are free and these apps
can help you you think great it sounds
like a deal but you're giving something
up in exchange for that free service
you're giving up your data should people
be concerned about privacy that's a
great question you know my answer to
that is um that breaches happen and we
need to be vigilant but also these apps
and these financial institutions are
also extra careful because if they can't
be secure and they lose our trust
they're out of business so a lot of
billions of dollars a year go into
protecting our data look for words like
data encryption a lot of these apps will
tell you on the home page or a quick
link how they are protecting our data
yeah yeah it does hurt them as much as
it hurts you when they get hacked all
incentivized yes but i'm me i'm not you
uh it's robbie furniture thank you very
much uh for new strawberry thank you
much uh we'll be right back
i'll bet you've heard that before
yeah
appreciate you being a good sport about
it